la petite sirène de copenhague reçoit
chaque jour la visite de milliers de
personnes elle est le symbole par
excellence de la ville mais d'année en
année un autre symbole à fait sa place
ici moins touristique certes mais
peut-être plus impressionnant encore le
vélo ici c'est dans la culture tout le
monde a sa bicyclette
que l'on soit jeune ou plus vieux seul
ou en famille
on utilise pour aller partout premières
constatations il y à des voies cyclables
partout grand copenhague
on y compte 1000 km de pistes séparées
des routes et exclusive au vélo dirk
copenhague prouve qu'elle en a encore
beaucoup à faire
ces cyclistes